for the five of you who may have caught
my Justice League War review you'll
probably remember that I said at the
time I was a little bit worried about
what it indicated for the future of the
DC Animated Universe that it was setting
the new continuity for now I love
nothing more than to have my skepticism
proved wrong it's one of my favorite
things as a viewer to go in with
something that I didn't think was going
to work and just be blown away by that
however did not
with Son of Batman because not only did
it meet all of my fears it blew them
completely out of the water
things get off on the wrong foot pretty
much right off the bat with a very
transparent attempt at maturity where
maturity here means a surprising amount
of gratuitous blood and violence and
taliao ghoul's magically lifted cleavage
seriously guys when you get a voice
actors with an inherent sensuality to a
voice like Miranda Baccarin you do not
need
actually in a lot of ways the opening
scene is pretty much a microcosm for
everything that is wrong with this film
sure the action scenes are cool but they
can't decide how stylized or realistic
they want to be case in point faceless
characters are gunned down in
spectacular fashion left and right while
important characters are deflecting a
veritable wall of bullets with a sword
plus it's apparently possible to take
down helicopters with the Gatling gun
that fires arrows and oh yeah there's a
Gatling gun that fires arrows this scene
also introduces the villain of the piece
in the form of Deathstroke and he's bad
and I don't mean in the way that you
want a villain to be bad I mean he's
really really bad I don't know who this
voice actor was but he did not give a
single line reading that I liked and the
real pain in the butt is the characters
written with a lot of different
emotional beats that he could be playing
jealousy anger arrogance and you get
none of that it is so insanely Bland
every single word that comes out of his
mouth there is just zero flavor every
time he speaks at all that it completely
undoes the work done by a cool character
designed and some good fight sequences
and then there is the titular Son of
Batman Damien Wayne he is everything you
hate about these tween Age characters
he's cocky with no right to be he's
spoiled he's pretentious he's violent to
the point of absurdity and his stubborn
refusal to listen to anyone who's giving
him solid advice maybe just cross my
fingers throughout for him to get his
little bastard ass kicked he is
seriously the embodiment of everything
that drove fans to kill Jason Todd in
the 1980s I'll admit to not having kept
up with the comics all that much but the
impression I get of Damien in the comics
is that readers hated him off the bat
but they grew to like him over time well
you know we've only got 75 minutes which
means we've got no time to grow with
this character and ever like him I hated
him I want to find some positive stuff
to say about this I mean it looks good
enough but the ball gets dropped on so
many fundamental levels that how good it
looks doesn't even matter seriously if
you're gonna up the violence quotient as
much as this movie does you have to have
that violence mean something otherwise
it is the epitome of gratuitous case in
point if you're going to have a
character's wrist pinned against the
wall with a knife once he gets his hands
off that wall you can't have him
continue to fight a peak efficiency as
if it was a paper cut even Batman's
legendary moral compass is completely
out of whack in this he chastises Damien
about Taking Lives which seems like a
lost cause anyway because one of the
first things we see this kid do is Cap a
guy in the head but then Batman goes on
this thing no using swords we don't kill
people but then only minutes later he
himself is using explosives to blow up a
stadium roof and Crush people apparently
once they are mutated into another form
and are no longer clearly identifiable
as human it's fine you can just kill him
left and right the only aspects of this
film that edge above being merely
passable is Alfred Nightwing and Batman
himself despite the moral relativism
Jason O'Mara gives another very solid
performance as Batman I like him as
Batman I want to see more of him as
Batman just not the way they're writing
him and these few high points they're
buried under so much complete junk it
doesn't matter that's two in a row now
that DC animated has missed the mark
this one way worse than the last one I
really hope that assault on Arkham gets
things back on track because seriously
this thing it it hurt to watch so with
Batman continuing to be the main go-to
character for these films what is a
Batman story from the comics that you
would like to see adapted into animated
form for me I'm partial to hush or maybe
on no man's land as a two-parter like
they did with Dark Knight Returns but
what about you drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it until
then I'll be back as soon as I get my
next fix
foreign